thanks for being here everybody thanks
for thanks for watching
I hope you had a great weekend remember
if you want to get the whole show to
subscribe on itunes or become a premium
member of the daily wire and that way if
you're watching on facebook you only get
15 minutes if you want the whole thing
you could do that on itunes or on daily
wire the Grammys were last night I just
just wanted to briefly mention it um I
only know that they happened because The
Daily Beast sent out a tweet outraged
that the wrong race had won Album of the
year so the tweet said the Grammys were
a glorious confounding mess but worst of
all is how a black person still hasn't
won Album of the year in over a decade
now I read that and I thought wait a
second I don't pay attention to this
stuff very closely but I'm pretty sure
minorities and women win the big Grammy
Awards all the time I mean that's just
my general impression so can we is there
really a diversity problem with the
Grammys so I went and looked it up just
out of curiosity and first of all a
black man won
song of the year this year which is a
big award but apparently that doesn't
count a Puerto Rican man won Album of
the year last year three black men or
groups have won over the last 15 years
women artists have won seven times over
that time spam white men have only won
four times so is that really not enough
diversity I mean you're still finding a
reason Takei is that is that is that not
what exactly is the / so what what is
that what percentage do we have in mind
like what are we supposed to hit is that
not is that not good enough by the way
whoever wrote this article for the beast
I just want you to think about the
process here okay they so they saw that
a white person so a white woman won this
year the country artist I think so they
saw that a white person won and they
thought okay how can I turn this into a
race thing we've got a white person
winning an award obviously there's a
race issue how can I do this so then
they thought let me go check in see how
long it's been since a minority won
Album of the year and then they went and
they checked and they saw that oh wait a
second Porto Rican guy won last year so
maybe the and and then they would have
seen that Oh a black you know
black people have won three times over
the last 15 years and rather than just
say okay nevermind I guess there's no
issue here not a big deal okay actually
there's a lot of diversity no instead
they decided to structure their
complaint in such a way as to get around
those facts so rather than complaining
about a lack of minorities winning they
singled it out to two black people in
particular and rather than complaining
about the last 15 or 20 years they chose
arbitrarily the last 10 years and if a
black person had won say nine years ago
they would have said well no one there
had there hasn't been a black person
winning in the last eight years you know
so they just whatever it is they're
looking for this is basically how the
how the identity politics sausage is
made and it's pretty it's pretty
annoying to see alright I want to talk
about something else something much more
important the Houston Chronicle
published a report over the weekend
about widespread sex abuse in the
Southern Baptist Church the story and
the details are eerily familiar to
anyone who has followed the scandals in
the Catholic Church which I have very
closely as I think you know so let me
read now a little bit from the
Huffington Post article on this it says
according to the three-part
investigation the first installment of
which was published on Sunday about 300
380 Southern Baptist pastors ministers
youth pastors Sunday School teachers
deacons and church volunteers have faced
allegations of sexual misconduct since
1998 more than 200 of them have been
convicted or took plea deals the
newspaper reported nearly 100 are
currently in prisons across the nation
the victims of the accused number more
than 700 the report said they include
teenagers and children some as young as
three who were molested or raped inside
pastors studies and Sunday School
classrooms many victims said their
stories of abuse were ignored or
silenced by church leaders one victim
who alleged she was raped and
impregnated by her pastor when she was a
team said her church leaders had urged
her to get an abortion when she refused
they threatened her and her child she
said dozens of pastors employees and
volunteers will report
allowed to return to work in southern
baptist churches despite being dogged by
sexual abuse allegations let me give you
some more just some sort of bullet
points this is now from the the Houston
Chronicle which as I said they they had
the original report about this it says
at least 35 church pastors employees and
volunteers who exhibited predatory
behavior we're still able to find jobs
at churches during the past two decades
in some cases church leaders apparently
failed to alert law enforcement about
complaints or to warn other
congregations about allegations of
misconduct several past presidents and
prominent alert leaders of the Southern
Baptist Convention are among those
criticized by victims for concealing or
Mis handling abuse complaints within
their own churches or seminaries some
registered sex offenders return to the
pulpit others remain there including a
Houston preacher who sexually assaulted
a teenager and now is the principal
office officer of a Houston nonprofit
that works with the student
organizations according to federal
records the name of this nonprofit is
touching the future today incorporated
many of the victims were adolescents who
are molested sent explicit photos or
text exposed to pornography photographed
nude or repeatedly raped by youth
pastors some victims as young as 3 were
molested or raped inside pastors studies
and Sunday School classrooms a few were
adults women and men who thought who
sought pastoral guidance and instead say
they were seduced or sexually assaulted
ok now keep something in mind here when
you have a a widespread scandal like
this and you have efforts to silence
victims which is what is happening here
and which is what always happens in
these kinds of cases you can be sure
that there are going to be more victims
a lot more victims than initial reports
indicate ok because only the victims who
were not successfully silenced are
counted but any of any victim who was
successfully terrorized or intimidated
or humiliated or shame
into keeping quiet will not be counted
in the statistics now if the Catholic
Church scandals have taught us anything
it is that in fact Catholic Church
church scandals have have taught or
shown us quite a bit speaking of which
you know anyone who's followed me for
any amount of time knows that I have
been very very very very vocal about sex
abuse in the Catholic Church I have
written thousands of words about it I
have spoken at rallies denouncing
bishops for their inaction I have called
as much attention as possible to this
issue I have spoken in the harshest
imaginable terms about the guilty
parties and those who aid and abet the
guilty parties I've called out the Pope
the bishops the Cardinals everyone okay
now I only point that out so that you
understand and as I said if you've been
following me for a while you you already
know this that I am NOT someone who's
looking to deflect from the Catholic
scandal who's looking to ignore it
no I want to call attention to it in
fact you know I reached a point of
people complaining to me and saying we
stopped talking about this issue it's
like all you talk about you know I went
through a period of like a month whereas
I felt like I was writing about it every
day but I but I thought I needed to
because this can't be ignored and it
needs to be exposed so I'm not someone
looking to deflect or change the subject
you know what about ISM nothing like
that I'm not looking to do that so when
I point to what's happening now in the
Baptist Church that's not my point my
point is I don't want those in the
Southern Baptist Church to make the same
mistake that Catholics made for so long
which was to be in denial to insist that
it's not so bad to claim that anyone
pointing to the problem might must just
be anti-catholic anti-christian they
must just have a grudge whatever I don't
want to see those same mistakes made and
it looks like they are being made and
now
just in the Baptist Church by the way as
I've mentioned in the past this is not
just a Catholic problem it's not just a
Baptist problem this is a problem in the
Christian Church this is a Christian
problem the three largest insurance
companies who insure many of the
Protestant churches in the u.s. have
reported that there are about 260 sex
abuse claims made against Protestant
church leaders every year in this
country and it's been going on at that
rate for years so not Catholic not
Baptist not Protestant this is this is a
problem in the church and in
Christianity now it's obviously not just
a Christian problem either it's a sin
problem it's a society problem it is a
human nature problem it is a where a
fallen species problem all that is true
yes there's a sex abuse crisis in the
public school in the Universities and
Hollywood and the media even in our
doctors offices there's a big problem
there too but the churches should be an
exception to that now I'm not saying
that churches should be a place where
only perfect people go because if there
were only for perfect people then then
then nobody would ever go to church
right but there's a pretty wide gap
between perfect person and sex predator
okay there's a there's a pretty wide
chasm and there's a lot of room in
between churches should be a place where
you can go and be safe and be away from
all of that and so it's not good enough
yeah we can look around and see oh every
single institution where there are
adults in children it looks like there's
a sex abuse epidemic and that's true but
we can't use that to deflect and say
well you know it's happening with
everyone I mean it's just it's
unavoidable the churches should be
different but they aren't and no
denomination is exempt not one you know
I tell you I was I was pretty troubled
yesterday I sent out a tweet yesterday
calling attention to this issue because
this report just came out
over the weekend and I think it's
something we all need to look at and
here's the tweet I sent out I said a new
report finds that over 300 Southern
Baptist church leaders have been accused
of sexual misconduct since 1988 to put
that in perspective the Catholic sex
scandal in Pennsylvania implicated 300
Catholic clergy over a period of 70
years my point here was obvious I
thought yes Pennsylvania is a smaller
area fewer churches but that scandal
stretched back 70 years most of the
cases were from decades ago many of the
Predators are now dead the issue in the
Southern Baptist Church is more recent
more immediate which isn't to say that
it's worse this is not a competition for
God's sake I was simply trying to
highlight the urgency and the immediacy
of the problem in the SBC and the point
is people were viscerally outraged
instinctively outraged about the
Pennsylvania scandal and rightly so okay
the fact that it was that a lot of it
was old that a lot of it was from years
ago that didn't stop anyone from being
from being extremely angry and demanding
action and it shouldn't have stopped
them and it didn't stop me and so what
I'm hoping is that that same kind of
visceral reaction the same level of
anger and outrage and calls for change
will arise also over this issue in the
SBC that's that's that's what I'm hoping
that's that's what I think should happen
because if you wanted to when you looked
at what happened in Pennsylvania was a
huge story everyone's talking about it
Christians all across the spectrum we're
outraged they were you know if you
wanted to you know if you want to find a
way to really split hairs and actually
look at what was being reported and you
wanted to find ways to diminish the
severity or you know deflect you could
have because you could have said well
most of these are you know they've
already put things that but most of the
stuff is from you know we're talking
about a lot of these cases happened 40
years ago and blah blah blah you could
have done that and there were some
Catholics who did try to do that but
most people didn't most people said yeah
you know what but who cares okay the
fact is this is a problem it's an
epidemic even if something happened 40
years ago it still happened it shouldn't
have so there needs to be there needs to
be accountability and so the same thing
should
happen here the problem is you know the
tweet that I sent out it did engender a
lot of outrage but at me
lots of people took the time to lecture
me on my inappropriate comparison and to
scold me for my wording and to insist
that to insist that know the Catholic
thing is so much worse and let's still
talk about that how dare I compare them
etc etc you know a lot of people are
getting mad at me about a tweet I sent
out and so I just had a curiosity some
of them I went to their pages to check
to see if they had tweeted anything
about the SPC scandal at all aside from
just lecturing me about the way in which
I call attention to it and what I found
of course is that a lot of people who
were taking time out of their day to
lecture one guy for the manner in which
he called attention to this crisis had
not themselves taken any time to call
attention to it themselves and this is
something I found you know not just
yesterday but anytime I've tried to call
attention to to the sex abuse problem in
other churches I have found that a lot
of people are very resistant to it they
don't want to hear it they want to think
that it's just a Catholic thing you know
my church is different it doesn't know
it's different here that's not the same
it's different we're different today I
posted a link to the Houston Chronicle
article with a you know this time just a
link with a simple caption saying this
is the tip of the iceberg you know
there's so just keep that in mind that's
all I said here are some of the
responses I received did you make a
similar comment after the Catholic
scandals emerged I know you're
embarrassed about the Catholic Church's
decades of abuse including thousands of
innocent children but to point to
another denomination and saying hey look
guys we're not the only ones that like
raping little boys is pretty sad clean
up your own house first you should pipe
down this humbling moment for American
Protestants could bring Catholics and
Protestants closer together and possibly
even help end cat' anti-catholic bigotry
unless Catholics like you continue doing
what about ISM I'm neither Baptist nor
Catholic but seriously what's your point
Matt whether it's 1 or 1 billion doesn't
matter sin is sin
ok Matt what's the next move then what
are you suggesting with
tweets shutdown SPC and Christianity I
don't understand the direction you're
heading with these tweets do you
understand why SB leaders decline to act
they don't have any authority to act on
this each church is governed by its
congregation headquarters mostly direct
creation of event content could you drop
the subject already
don't be silly they are human like any
other group they're going to have
problems like any other group are you
biased against a Baptist Church for some
reason excuse making deflecting pipe
down
don't talk about this no let's talk
about that over there instead not this
no this is different
this is why it's different oh no they
didn't have any choice they had to hire
the Predators that whatever they
supposed to do there's nothing else they
could do excuses excuses excuses
people are cowards I mean this is just
that you know how pathetic that is but I
could post an article - hey guys look at
this look at this crisis going on and
and those are the responses don't talk
about this pipe down
you're biased against Baptists people
don't want to face it
they don't want to think that these
things can be happening close to home
it's the same reason why no one wants to
hear about the sex abuse crisis in the
public school I've talked about this
many times I mentioned recently how you
know I wrote an article a few months ago
about the sex abuse crisis of public
school because that's a problem I would
think Ally tens of millions of kids are
in that system and and and and thousands
of them are being sexually abused
according to every statistic you'll find
it's a problem huge problem epidemic
crisis tried to write an article about
it and a lot of the responses were why
are you talking about this why look no
it's the cat let's talk about Catholic
Church instead why are you trying to
deflect no it's not the same oh you're
exaggerating now no we've got to be
better than this in the church in the
Christian Church we've just we've got to
be better than this and if we can
in you having this attitude nothing will
ever get better and like I said in the
Catholic Church this is this is the
attitude that a lot of Catholics had in
the beginning you know these scandals
first erupted back in the early 2000s
back I don't know 15 years ago or
something and or whatever it was and I
was a kid back then but I remember I
remember how a lot of Catholics reacted
to it and it was they were pretty
defensive and it took a while now you're
not gonna find that now most most
Catholics that come across are not so
defensive about it anymore
and they're gonna be the first ones to
bring up this problem and to demand
change and and but it did take a while
to get to that point but that is
inexcusable and cowardly and now we're
seeing the same thing with this alright
let's check in briefly with the saga of
Alexandria kZO cortezes green New Deal
you remember last week when the proposal
the plan was released and we had a
glorious time making fun of it the thing
was just so fantastically insane that it
almost had a certain charm to it you
know it was kind of cute in a way it's
like when my two year old the other day
my two year old came up to me to present
me with a gift of Pocket lint
and he said here daddy for you and so I
took the pocket let when I said oh wow
thanks this is great and then I threw it
away as soon as he turned his back right
and so you were tempted to do the same
thing with the green new deal because it
was there was something almost almost
adorable about it that it was just so
childish and so you were almost tempted
to say oh wow a really good good job
nice nicely done and then you know just
chuck it in the bin but then you realize
that the people came up with this deal
are actually adults in Congress
proposing this thing in a serious way
and then once you realize that sudden
the whole situation becomes quite a lot
darker so the nuttiest part of the plan
was this FAQ frequently asked question
sheet that was published by Cortes
congressional office and it contained
all the stuff about about giving money
to people who are quote unwilling to
work and it had stuff about farting cow
getting rid of farting cows and so on so
then mysteriously on Friday the FAQ
sheet was gone from the website taken
down and Cortez owner and her people
started claiming that it had been
doctored by Republicans and this is some
sort of conspiracy and Republicans had
managed to doctor the document and
somehow post it on their website that's
what they originally claimed anyway and
then which of course was insane and
people were making fun of that so then
they back pedaled and they said oh no no
that was our proposal but it was a draft
proposal not the real one and somehow it
ended up online by mistake but there are
still some problems here problems remain
even if it was just a draft proposal
first of all the rest of the plan is
still insane even without the farting
cows and the income for people who
aren't willing to work it's still insane
second this rough draft excuse that just
means that if this is a rough draft then
then it just it gives us a look at what
they really have in mind and what they
really want to do so in many ways if it
was a rough draft which I don't believe
for a minute by the way that it really
was I think they're just lying to cover
their butts here I think they put this
thing out in all seriousness and people
just got such a reaction and everyone
was just laughing at it which is really
the last thing that you want right when
you when you put out a legislative
proposal it's if people disagree with it
or angry about it okay that's one thing
but if people are just laughing
hysterically at the at the proposal well
then you know you've you know that's a
problem so I think that happened and
they just took it down and now they're
lying to try to find a way around it but
even if it were true okay even if this
was a rough draft then it's actually
worse in some ways because it would mean
that they unintentionally revealed their
true plans and actually showed us they
actually showed us the the difference
between how they present the plan to the
public or how they meant how they wanted
to present it to the public verse what
they actually want to do which doesn't
make them or the plan look any better so
if you're hearing that oh that ever what
everyone was freaking out about it's a
rough draft don't worry about it no you
should still be worried about it okay
that doesn't change anything all right
before we wrap up I want to look at a
few emails check the Inbox
if you want to send a message email to
the show you can do that at Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com all right this is from Josh
she says Matt I recently got into a
debate with an atheist about how God
doesn't exist because if we do not
believe in God or Jesus we cannot make
it into heaven he proceeded to
site-to-site the Bible by saying in John
14:6 no one can come to heaven but
through Jesus his proof then that God
does not exist is what about people who
never heard about Jesus
Native Americans Aztecs etc being damned
to hell for eternity because they were
never given the moral compass that is
Christianity and how can God dam people
to hell without hearing the word of God
I tried to explain that one he was not
there among those natives who he is
referencing how can he know they were
never given the moral compass to Western
civilization is founded on Christianity
and is more successful than any other
civilization ever conceived
including natives and Aztec
civilizations I didn't feel satisfied
with the explanation I gave him what
rebuttals do you have after hearing his
argument
thanks love your show okay hi Josh
thanks for the message I'd say a few
things to your atheist friend your
second point about your second point
about the success of Western
civilization is true but that really
doesn't have any bearing on whether or
not God exists right but also this isn't
really an argument about the existence
of God your friend is not making an
argument that has anything to do with
the existence of God because even if he
were right
Madore unjust or whatever for people
who've never heard of Jesus to go to
hell that that would do nothing to
disprove God
you know maybe if you were right about
that and that does nothing does nothing
at all about about the existence of God
so it's it's it's got nothing to do with
the subject but I think the more
important point here is that no serious
or thoughtful Christian believes that
all of the millions or billions of
people who existed and died in parts of
the world where the gospel never reached
automatically went to hell a serious or
thoughtful Christian is not going to
make that declaration as if they know
right now you may have unserious and
unthoughtful Christians who will say
stuff like that but I think your atheist
friend has a responsibility to engage
with the serious Christian arguments not
the unserious ones because that's called
a straw man otherwise now the gospel
didn't make it to this henan hemisphere
until fourteen hundred years after
Christ and it took another several
hundred years before it had reached
every corner of this part of the world
and it absolutely is not a Christian
teaching that all of those people went
to hell for all eternity for because
they didn't hear something that they
never had a chance to hear now scripture
teaches us that no one goes to heaven
but through Christ which means that
Christ decides he is the calls himself
the doorway he's the door he decides who
who is going who the gates of heaven
will be open to and and who not he
separates the sheep from the goats so
are we gonna sit here and say that
Christ cannot is not allowed to doesn't
have the power to admit someone who
didn't fully know him in life into
heaven are we gonna say that Christ
can't put such a person with the Sheep
no I certainly won't say that and and
that's not the traditional Christian
teaching and most Christians won't say
that
third thing people are judged based on
the information available to them okay
so what that means is yeah if nobody
ever told you about Jesus and you
weren't there to see it for yourself
then there's no way you could possibly
know unless he appears to you but you
know it's in some sort of vision but
outside of that which would which would
also be you know that in that case
you're still being told about it so if
nobody tells you about it then you're
not gonna know but everybody has a
conscience
everyone everyone knows basic right from
wrong and this is called natural law
this is the natural law that God has
written on our hearts so that even an
Aztek could follow this law could live
by it even if they don't know fully what
they're doing or who they're obeying
they still have it there in their heart
so while a person can't be blamed for
not believing in Christ if Christ has
never been presented to them they can be
blamed for committing objective acts of
evil because they did know better they
are without excuse as far as that goes
and as proof of this fact just look at
any civilization that's ever existed on
earth it is a remarkable fact that they
all have the same fundamental kinds of
laws all of them okay they all outlaw
murder they outlaw rape they outlaw
theft they as a society they encourage
heroism they encourage her courage the
generosity virtue every society is like
this now you might say well what about
the Nazis or what about those Aztecs who
were committing human sacrifices on such
an enormous scale well yes that's true
but murder wasn't legal in Nazi Germany
neither was it legal in the Aztec empire
no it's just that it wasn't considered
murder to kill a Jew or or to you know
commit a human sacrifice now does that
make it okay of course not
it was it still murder obviously they
they might not have called it murder
they might have tried to pretend that it
wasn't but it still was objectively
speaking my point is only that the
Nazis even the Nazis as depraved and
evil as they were they still felt the
need to kind of work around this natural
law that was on even their hearts so
even they weren't gonna come out and say
yeah you know what murder is fine do
what you want instead they tried to
rationalize that murder wasn't murder we
do the same thing with abortion murder
is illegal in this country but you can
still kill babies it but isn't killing
babies murder yes it absolutely is but
the people who do it feel feel the need
still you know no one's gonna come out
and say yeah you know what let's murder
base five murders fine
no they're conscious because they had
they have that they have a conscience
they recognize at some level that it's
wrong and so they feel the need to kind
of rationalize work around it and the
rationalizations are crazy but the fact
that they feel the need to make those
rationalizations at all really tells you
something so ironically you know the
Holocaust and abortion they really only
prove the existence of the moral law the
natural law because even the propagators
of those kinds of evils still felt the
need to work around it and if there was
no such law if there was no natural law
if there was no fundamental moral truth
which by the way also proves the
existence of God because what is that
moral truth grounded in where does it
come from and if it was released totally
based on society it was completely
arbitrary completely subjective then
when you look around the world
especially when you go back 500 years
and you find that the - you know that
the two hemispheres were separated and
there was no contact between them or
hardly any contact what you should find
is vastly different laws I mean you foot
you should find civilizations where
murder was okay rape was fine it was
explicitly fine like there was no you
know it was but you don't find that
which is pretty incredible when you
think about it so that's what I would
say to your friend all right from Daniel
he says dear Matt Walsh I wanted to take
a moment to thank you for what you're
doing your daily podcast I'm a Christian
who has often been impressed
the genuine thoughtfulness and insight
on your daily show why I'm just reading
this to compliment myself I guess sorry
about that you recently recommended
reading the problem of pain by seus
Lewis being that CS Lewis is one of my
favorite authors I gladly pick up the
book
I enjoyed following Lewis's reasoning
throughout the book and especially found
my thinking shifting on how I look at
God in that he is the creator and I am
the created object desperately in need
of him I'm a mechanical engineer working
at a firm which designs power plans what
I am daily struck by is the potential
Ness of those I work with I am unsure of
how often you've been around engineers
but they like to attack as if they have
the whole world figured out speaking as
a professional engineer myself I can
assure you that the engineers truly do
not know everything being a conservative
minded Christian in the workplace I've
found that I'm treated as ignorant when
bringing up anything dealing with God or
politics this is frustrating and
disappointing in that my faith is not a
blind faith but rather a reasonable
faith however even when presenting a
perfectly reason throw argument it is
quickly dismissed as brutish and
uneducated encountering this on an
almost daily basis I'm reminded of psalm
119 I have more understanding than all
my teachers for thy testimonies are my
meditation I understand that the only
way to truly know the word around the
world around us is to understand and
know God
however since my co-workers refused to
know God they quickly dismiss into ride
views that do not line up with their
narrowly constructed and logically
inconsistent mindsets I want to thank
you for exposing and seeking truth truth
and to let you know that you are dealing
curves them to me well thank you Daniel
for that and we certainly need
Christians like you who are in those
environments as hostile as they might be
to your to your faith but I appreciate
your courage in any case all right all
let's say we read one more I wanted to
get to this one okay this is from Alana
she says Alana Elena I think she says hi
Matt you raised the question on Twitter
a while ago about what would happen if
we split a brain in two and transplanted
it in two different bodies I've been
thinking about it ever since
fascinating question but you never gave
your own answer so what do you think
would happen okay so this requires too
much
my agent I raised the question a while
ago on Twitter it's a question
originally posed by a philosopher whose
name I cannot remember at the moment but
the idea is the idea is to is to kind of
get at the nature of consciousness and
to understand consciousness and so it
goes like this we know that a person can
survive with half a brain we also know
about the split brain phenomenon where
something goes wrong in the brain and
essentially the two sides disconnect
from each other and then you end up with
a literal split personality almost like
two two sides of a personality that
don't recognize or even know about each
other because the two halves work
independently of each other so we know
about those cases we also know
theoretically that it will probably one
day be possible to perform a brain
transplant taking a brain out of one
body putting it into another we're a
long way from that but hypothetically
theoretically it could be possible so
here's the question what if you were to
take half of my brain and Transplant it
into someone else's head where would I
be you know where where did my
consciousness go my identity where am I
am I now in two places so that's the
thought experiment experiment and yes I
know I've opened myself up to jokes
about how I only have half a brain to
begin with so I don't have much despair
I get that but once you've gotten those
jokes out of your system what's the
answer to the to the thought experiment
now I'm not exactly sure how to answer
it I would have to say this is why I
posed the question and didn't answer it
because I don't have one I would have to
say I would have to assume that well
this is kind of a cop-out answer but I
guess the answer is that it just
couldn't ever be possible to do that
even if it's theoretically medically
scientifically possible it wouldn't
actually be possible because it's not
possible to split a person's soul in two
and we know that in this life on earth
our soul is somehow inextricably
linked with our brains now we don't
understand that relationship exactly the
mind the soul whatever you want to call
it the soul in the mind the soul in the
brain are not just dualities but also a
harmony so we know that we know the soul
is immutable you know into soluable
cannot be cut in half so I would have to
say that God would not allow something
like that to work I guess another way of
putting it is that this is something
that even if it were physically possible
it's not metaphysically possible and so
it just couldn't happen which is a
totally lame answer but but that's all I
got if anyone has an answer to that
question that doesn't require you to
compromise on the idea of a soul and yet
as a better answer than mine then I'd be
interested to hear anyway all right
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed